The decades-long
opioid epidemic
in the US was once
dominated by drugs like
heroin and oxy.
But with the rise of fentanyl,
perhaps the most
dangerous phase
is now upon us.
In the first two years
of the pandemic,
more people were killed
by fentanyl than ever before.
The Covid pandemic helped
pave the way for
fentanyl's ascent,
as isolation and boredom
drove people to
substance abuse.
There have been
more than 165,000
opioid deaths since
the start of Covid.
Most of those deaths involved
synthetic opioids like fentanyl.
Fentanyl was first
developed as a stronger
kind of painkiller.
It's cheap
and the street version
is abundant.
It's more than 100 times
more powerful than morphine
and 50 times more
powerful than heroin.
Just two milligrams of fentanyl
around the size
of a few grains of salt
can cause a fatal overdose.
Fentanyl is now infiltrating
other kinds of drugs,
including heroin and cocaine,
as well as counterfeit
prescription pills.
That means people with an
opioid addiction are at risk,
and so are users of cocaine,
black-market Adderall,
meth, marijuana,
and other substances.
The powerful drug is often
used to strengthen or stretch
stockpiles of other illicit drugs.
The precursor chemicals
used to make
fentanyl are also
globally available,
according to the Drug
Enforcement Administration.
A lot of illicit fentanyl
is made abroad
and smuggled into
the US through Mexico.
In Florida,
Governor Ron DeSantis
described the situation
as a problem of law enforcement
and border control.
He has responded by increasing
Florida's penalties
for opioid sale and distribution,
and he announced a program
that connects patients
with treatments
like naltrexone and methadone
to help treat addiction.
Similar techniques,
like syringe exchanges
are part of what's known as
harm reduction,
a movement
to decrease the risks
associated with drug use.
But some harm-reduction
techniques have been rejected
by conservative elected officials
who say they instead
enable drug use.
Another tactic is the distribution
of fentanyl strips,
which can be used to test
for the powerful substance
in other drugs.
But the strips are considered
illegal drug paraphernalia
in about half of US states,
including Florida,
according to Kaiser Health News.
Florida's Republican-controlled
legislature recently
shut down an effort
to change that.
In Florida,
which skews older
and is more than
a quarter Hispanic,
most of those
who are dying
of opioid overdoses are white,
and more than half
are younger than 45.
But with fentanyl use
on the upswing,
the death rate among
Black people
has overtaken White people,
and overdoses among
Native Americans are also
increasing disproportionately.
And we have a crisis
at the US-Mexico border
over the past year
that's witnessed
staggering amounts
of illegal migration
and a massive influx of
narcotics such as fentanyl.